thanks for coming here today folks
i think some of you here or most of you
here last friday we announced a series
of
increased efforts on our part to reduce
if not eliminate the full demonstration
in the safest
most effective and lawful manner
possible
we talked about the surge in contain
since that time we've had twenty arrests
and charges criminal arrests and charges
of individuals who have broken the law
directly or indirectly in regards to
this demonstration
we've issued over 500 tickets to those
individuals who've come here
mostly in conveyances trucks
suvs cars
for an awful conduct
bylaws provincial offenses and criminal
code offenses we have towed vehicles and
we have towed trucks
there has been a significant decrease in
the amount of protesters and vehicles
associated to the protesters over that
time period
the large demonstration that was planned
for this weekend was significantly
smaller than the previous weekend
the previous weekend had three thousand
plus trucks not counting all the other
vehicles
ten to fifteen thousand protesters
that took a 24 7 cycle over friday
saturday and sunday
this weekend the numbers are down around
a thousand trucks
around 5 000 protesters and while there
was some activity on saturday there was
almost no activity on friday or on
sunday
that is in direct reaction to our
stepped-up enforcement our surge in
contain and our aggressive intelligence
and investigation operations that have
been taking place over the last four
days and will continue until the end of
this demonstration
what particularly has occurred of the
significant nature
we went after the funding
our efforts combined with the city's
efforts eliminated the gofundme 10
million dollars are no longer accessible
to the demonstrators there are other
funding avenues that we continue to
aggressively go after through
intelligence information coordination
with financial institutions and all
three levels of government we will be
relentless in pursuing the funding that
has enabled this demonstration to
continue to this point
we're going after the fuel
we're going after any vehicle conveyance
including horseback
people carrying jerry cans
we are arresting and seizing and we are
interdicting fuel going into the
demonstrations
last night was a major public order
operation
we tried to end it through negotiation
as we always will do in every aspect
when that failed we went into a public
order operation it included covert
assets as well as investigation
intelligence intelligence assets
seven people were arrested and charged
criminally thousands of liters of
propane and fuel were seized
and we took out an oil tanker and the
entire footprint of the staging area at
coventry park that includes hot tubs and
saunas and anything else that was down
there we've erected fences in that area
and are going to secure that area so
there are no more incursions
over the course of the weekend through
negotiation efforts we peacefully and
fully resolved
the confederation park encampment no
arrests no use of force no injuries no
deaths no riots no encampment in
confederation park
it is god we have fenced in that area
and reclaimed that territory
expectation setting let me be clear
every time we knock something down there
are attempts for it to pop up in four or
five other locations we're rapidly
deploying our resources whenever we get
a sense of another fuel depot another
staging area or anything else that
enables the demonstration to continue we
send resources in there we reclaim that
property and we allow ourselves to get
incremental advancements towards the end
of the demonstration
over the last four days in addition to
those operations they will continue on
to be clear
we have been seeking additional
resources provincially and federally and
of course municipally
we've been working very closely with
city manager steve kanilakis the mayor's
office and as and our board in order to
seek additional funds there is a formal
request that will be sent to the mayor's
office in the next hour requesting a
significant increase in police resources
civilian resources as well as requests
for significant increases for bylaw
offenses fines and other enabling orders
of government to allow us to more fully
and effectively and quickly as well as
lawfully and safely end this
demonstration
we are turning up the heat in every way
we possibly can within our operations
and enforcement as well as in our
engagement of all three levels of
government
every available ottawa police service
officer has been working for the last
four days let me repeat we have canceled
days off
there is nobody on a day off getting
rest over the last four days some
officers are on their 14th day straight
of 12 hours in a row during the coldest
snap in in ottawa in the last 10 years
working outside continuously
no officers are on days off everyone has
been working
we are stretched to the limit but we are
one hundred percent committed to using
everything we have to end this
demonstration we cannot do it alone that
is why i have been advocating for all
three levels of government to bring
whatever they can bear bring to bear on
the permanent sustainable lawful safe
resolution of this demonstration
the opp the rcmp at least seven
different municipal police agencies have
embedded their officers within our
incident command structure that has
allowed us to get the relief we need to
move ottawa police officers into the
aggressive mode that you have seen over
the last four days we need more we are
grateful for what they have provided but
we need more
we are advocating for more levels of
government to do more things around
provincial interprovincial and national
strategies to address what is happening
here in the nation's capital
we'll be speaking to council within the
next hour to lay out the resource
requests that we ask the mayor to send
to the provincial solicitor general and
to public safety canada to significantly
increase our resources so we can
significantly escalate our enforcement
and interdictions in and around the
demonstration sites
let me be very clear about one thing as
hard as we have worked and as much as
our people are on the breaking point
the community has worked as hard or
harder and are closer to their breaking
point the stories coming to me are
breaking my heart
i have my own officers who live in and
around those areas and they and their
children have not been able to sleep
they and their children have not been
able to go to school this is crushing
for those residents and their businesses
it has to stop and we are doing
everything we can possibly do to stop it
we need more help we're asking for that
help we're starting to receive that help
but we need more to get this done
last but not least i want to thank the
members of this police service every
single one civilian or sworn front line
or executive we have been a hundred
percent full out on this for the last 10
days straight and we will not rest until
it's done but we need more help i thank
the front line men and women who've been
out there in sub 30 degree celsius
temperatures for 12 hours straight i
thank our communications operators who
have been receiving hate and threats all
day long 24 7. i thank our financial
people for trying to put together the
resources to sustain this i thank
everybody and anybody in our community
from counselors to bias to service
providers to the not-for-profit sector
to residents to school teachers to make
this the most livable thing that we can
to get through it we cannot do it alone
we have not been doing it alone but we
are making real strides and we will
continue to aggressively pursue that in
every aspect going forward thank you
very much and i'd love to take your
questions
you know the the protesters said we're
only two here the protesters laid out
their plan well in advance before coming
into ottawa yes you're turning up the
heat now but all of these plants they
said they did exactly what they said
that they were going to do and
a lot of ottawa residents say this is a
failure of the ottawa police and
ultimately the responsibility lies with
you why is this all happening the second
week into the game thank you very much
for your question um
this is an unprecedented protest
i'm not aware of anybody who has any
experience in managing large-scale
demonstrations whether they be a police
officer or whether they be a public
official who has not already gone on
record stating very clearly this is an
unprecedented protest never seen in
canada and i've heard from colleagues
around the world very rarely have they
ever seen anything like this
so i'll just finish answering my
question answering the question thank
you
so yes there were certainly indications
around which this would be a
demonstration
all of our negotiations with the corps
convoy stated that they would be here on
friday and they would leave on sunday
those negotiations were well in place
days in advance before they came
while there were fringe elements that
said everything from insurrection
through to negotiation our core
negotiations were a demonstration for
three days in the nation's capital and
the return of of those vehicles and
demonstrators to the parts of canada
they came from that is what we planned
for that is what we executed there was a
success around containing that as it
turned into more than a demonstration we
have pivoted and we pivoted immediately
we needed more resources to deal with a
occupation than with a demonstration i
have worked continuously 18-hour days to
get those resources our partners have
started to bring those resources to bear
and as they come in and as we reduce the
size of the footprint that has been in
place for the last 10 days we redeploy
those resources now we can go on the
offensive that's what we've been doing
to great effect just to follow up just
for clarification though chief are you
saying
that the ottawa police were caught off
guard that the protesters stayed as long
as they
stayed
so the ottawa police service have been
able to quell the la the large
demonstration that came in
as it's turned into an occupation we've
been able to pivot and get the resources
to go on offense to remove that
demonstrate occupation while still
managing the elements of the
demonstration
we have seen the challenges to our
neighborhoods and our businesses we've
seen the challenges to our officers in
delivering on that we are making
significant progress since we have made
that pivot over the last four days we
need more resources to drive those
successes even further and we might need
more levels of government to play their
role in the overall sustainable end to
this demonstration why did it take 10
days for the honorable police to start
confiscating fuel from the protesters
i'm not sure that's an accurate
statement we have been here
thank you very much for your question we
have been interdicting the fuel to the
extent that we can we did not have the
resources early in the week as we get
more resources we're able to do more
interdictions that's why we could do the
operation last night to the scale that
we did we need to maintain and increase
these resources so that we cannot just
get on the fuel we can get to the trucks
themselves
police chief there are still
demonstrators filling their trucks with
fuel we spoke to protesters at the
coventry site this morning after last
night's raid about how they still have
two days worth of heating fuel and
they're confident they'll be able to
replenish that what do you believe last
night's
operation at the site accomplished in
terms of bringing this demonstration to
an end thank you excellent question and
again we've been trying to say this this
is not a simple demonstration where if
you deal with one set of charges or one
particular location that's the end there
is a level of sustainability financial
capability determined commitment around
whatever the range of causes and i've
lost track of all the range of causes
where we get a success in one area we
get an immediate counter reaction in
multiple other areas it's not like a
consecutive movement end that then deal
with that and then deal with that that
has been the challenge from the
beginning that is why the current
structure of this police service the
funding and resources of this police
service is not sufficient to deal with
all of this we need more resources more
help with what we've got we've made
significant impact but we're going to
need a lot more to really get on top of
this situation
that letter is being drafted to the
mayor i'm sure it'll become a very
public document very soon i'm sending it
to the mayor he will be sending it to
the solicitor general and then on to
public safety canada we've had meetings
as of this morning with those two levels
of government they know what is coming
their way
they will have it within the next hour
those discussions will continue on no
doubt this evening last week though
we've been making requests since before
they arrived in town we've been
receiving resources as everyone gets an
understanding of the level that we've
needed but we're not going incremental
anymore we're asking for a major push of
resources to come in the next 72 hours
thank you very much folks thank you